and our shutout tonight is for a veteran
reporter who has now become his own boss
and his own editor
Jerry Mitchell has created the
Mississippi Center for Investigative
Reporting and continues to stir things
up as you will see going back following
up on old stories to make sure officials
keep to their promises to make things
better with the cell phone call from the
inmate back in 2013 hey I'm gonna tell
you about all the corruption that's
going on inside of prison and all these
beatings and various things that are
happening and nothing's being done about
him it was a call to action for
investigative journalist Jerry Mitchell
six years ago leading to a damning
expose in the Clarion Ledger in Jackson
Mississippi and a series of supposedly
forms in the state prison system things
getting worse so once again Mitchell is
on the case now turning up evidence of
how the understaffed prisons are really
being run by criminal gangs in lockdown
we joined the Mississippi Center for
Investigative Reporting and ProPublica
to investigate critical understaffing
this video obtained by the Marshall
project shows what officials call a gang
ordered murder on an inmate seen running
from his attackers trying to get away
trapped in a shower cell stabbed 10
times and left for dead one of four gang
killings inside this prison alone it's a
horrible situation and basically even
top prison officials have admitted that
the gangs are in charge of these prisons
so we've uncovered all these things of
how gangs control how prisons operate
how did it come to be that the gangs not
the warden and the guards from the
prison well if you don't have enough
officers like at night if all you have
is a tower officer and really know what
they call floor walkers I mean we expose
in South Mississippi Correctional
Institution time after time this
happened so as a journalist this is a
real challenge because you can't be in
side there you have to rely on them
talking at you and can you trust their
accounts how do you verify and
double-check this I'll tell you that's
great well you you piece it together use
inmates you use reports you use incident
reports and things like that
use correctional officers who work there
really to kind of get a picture I love I
love reporting on hidden worlds and this
is like one of them it's become a big
issue in Mississippi this cell phone
video surfaced last week and once again
Mitchell's investigative reporting is
making waves in Mississippi in part of
the prison on fire
investigate evey have uncovered alarming
staff shortages at prisons across the
country there is simply not enough
manpower in place to keep tabs on the
more than three thousand inmates that
are housed there silence most of this
time you know they kind of do circle
wagons but prison officials have
acknowledged the problem when you don't
have the appropriate level of staff you
know safety is a concern before his new
series on prison expose ace Mitchell
made big news when he obtained this
photograph of three Mississippi college
students posing with guns in front of
the bullet-ridden sign commemorating the
death of Emmett Till a 14 year old
african-american who was lynched in 1955
after being accused of the rape of a
white woman a friend of mine say this
looks like a trophy shot so instead of
you know ten point five they're standing
in front of the Emmett Till song you
know it's just very sturdy the three
students all members of an Ole Miss
paternity or suspended another black eye
for Mitchell's home state as a reporter
you know you know your your obligation
is not to protect somebody's reputation
it's our artists to tell the truth so
you're really filling a huge gap in
local investigative journalism we really
feel we are Brian
I know you feel I feel you know
investigative reporting is so key it's
so important to our democracy to to make
it work right we have to know about
citizens have to have knowledge what's
really going on
indeed so our shout out tonight for
Jerry Mitchell on the Mississippi Center
for Investigative Reporting and all
those who have supported it including
our own executive producer Rhonda
Schwartz who serves on the center's
board that's our program for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you back here next week